I'm not in my most photogenic it's been
a long day but some updates on the
strike Drew Barrymore reversed course
and is no longer bringing back the show
and instead we'll wait until the strike
is over this is a good thing because
first of all it's good for the strike
second of all it's just heartening to
see someone head down the wrong path
double down and make it seem like
they're gonna keep going and then
actually reverse course it seems so rare
that anyone changes their mind anymore
instead of just doubling tripling
quadrupling down and she didn't and uh
in accordance with that Jennifer Hudson
And The Talk are also now waiting that
leaves the view which has been going for
a little bit and uh Bill Maher starting
to feel lonely up on that Hill bill
sure you want to die up there
because you might do it alone I'll be
genuinely curious to see if he swaps
back or not
he's he's the one I have the least
respect for if he couldn't have guessed